The Joe Rogan Experience they're going
to be able to reverse aging in our
lifetimes I think I think by the time
you and I are old as [__] they'll
probably have figured out a way to turn
the clock backwards because they've
already had some experimental uh things
they've done with mice that have been
effective and they think that they're
very close to me
yeah and manipulate and probably you
don't want facts and you turn the
Benjamin Button and you're a [__]
baby again right you go you turn it
that's gonna be a delicate one where
Madonna just shows up looking like a
baby there's gonna be people that
identify as babies as they want to be
babies and so then we find out that
they're in preschool and they tell them
you have babies to get them cigarettes
like what the [__] is going on he's
really dead he's really 60. he's not a
baby just wanted to do it all over again
and you die he dialed himself back to
two years old but with a 60 year old's
brain and it's a great movie you think
that's happening what's that idea take
it that's a huge one so you think that
like within the next 10 years I mean the
way things are moving right now is crazy
even with like Chad you know Chad gbt
the way it was like four months ago
versus now like things are on the Move
yeah it's the exponential increase in
technological innovation it's like the
way things happen they happen in these
big giant waves and then these
Technologies feed other new technologies
and I think it's going to be the case
with all of I think it's Medical Science
and I think it's technology and I think
there's going to be a combination of the
two of them eventually there's going to
be something that technology uh devises
that can fix a lot of problems that
people have that's one of the uses of
neural link they think it's going to be
able to help people that are injured and
hurt yeah there's parts of their body
they can restore movement yeah and it's
going to be one of the first ways to use
it it's gonna there's ones that have
they're coming out what they're going to
be able to reverse blindness you're
going to be able to give people the
ability to see Mr Beast in some sort of
artificial
but like an artificial eyeball
so is it is it a camera is that
essentially What It Is Well it's an it's
going to function the same way an
eyeball does but it's going to send
images to your brain instead of through
the normal biological course that you
know it is now where you're looking
through your eyes and the rods and cones
and everything goes through and you're
you see what's going on what you're
going to do is get a digitalized version
of that you're going to get an A
computer version of fake eyeballs
it's gonna be a wild like and then once
that's connected to the internet and
then just gonna be bizarre looking into
someone's fake eyeballs the Chad gbt
thing made it where I'm just like yo are
people just gonna have conversations
with like two computers like it's just
gonna be two computers talking to each
other look at this brain implants
startup backed by Bezos and Gates is
testing mind controlled Computing on
humans what the [__] dude I mean people
can't like this God damn it MK Ultra
Pam K Ultra you know what it's like
sometimes with the conspiracies you're
like listen there's a lot of people
thinking a lot of conspiracy stuff right
now can you take it easy for a second
there you go yeah yeah well but anyways
but those guys are crazy anyways we're
gonna put chips in the brains within the
week and you'll go take it easy what is
uh what what is the latest on the
artificial eye thing the thing that I
was just describing I don't know how
much of what I said was fiction they
showed something during the last neural
LinkedIn that you were describing that
shows an ability to get light through in
like pixelation form and they have it I
think it was somewhere around the range
of like 10 pixels now and I think they
get up to 36 000 I think I think there
was something else that I read that was
independent of that that was talking
about a new technology where they might
be able to create artificial eyes
oh something not in early yeah I think I
think it's all going to be eventually
linked in
um I think within our lifetime I think
they're going to have some sort of a
brain enhancement eyes is wild yeah
there's going to be some sort of a brain
enhancement with whether it's neural
link or many competing companies that
are working towards the same goal feels
like it's going to happen soon but if
they if they start doing that like I
wonder where we we draw the line that
things getting replaced similar
something posted a year ago bionic eyes
how Tech is replacing lost Vision bionic
eyes could be the solution to one of the
most pressing medical issues of our time
yeah I think that's using like
sunglasses and sensors
the creation of bionic eyes as a result
of recent advances in science and
technology are restoring hope to many
who are unable to see or partially cited
due to injury illness or genetics
yeah there you go also there's going to
be a good while where if you are blind
you could tell people you didn't get the
surgery and girls would still change in
front of you
yeah that's rude how dare you Ryan
there'd be a few creeps to be like for
sure blind there's three dudes out there
with the Ray Charles glasses on
pretending the line is a bad how many
guys have pretended to be blind what an
evil thing to do yeah that used to be a
genre of like internet videos of like
the blind guy what a creepy thing
that's bad karma oh super creepy but how
how long do you think before we have
like Luke Skywalker type arms where they
can replace your arm with something that
looks just like a normal human arm do
people not have kind of close versions
to that I mean at least they can grip
and stuff like that they can grip yeah I
don't I don't exactly know how it works
but um they they do have the ability to
open and close their hands I don't know
if they can individually articulate each
finger yet yeah there's just there's a
lot of money out there there's a lot of
people working on this stuff there's a
lot of you know but it's like even just
the amount of the crypto money being
poured into different projects right now
if they had fake legs that worked way
better than real legs and you could
literally like jump over fences and run
50 miles an hour wouldn't you get them
I don't think Orion it's not that big a
surgery if I was 20 it's not the biggest
surgery bro it's no big deal to just cut
your legs off
they cut your legs off and people be
signing up for it well you got to do it
one leg at a time because you don't want
to bleed out yeah yeah what the [__] are
you people getting the dollar surgery
there right now the dollar store the
taller surgery that's so crazy dude they
chop apparently it's like the like the
most painful thing you could imagine
kind of thing too oh God but um
oh exoskeletons [__] yeah yeah can you
imagine finding out that one guy cheated
in like hockey or something and you go
how did he cheat you go oh yeah he has
fake legs right yeah he doesn't feel
pain his knees don't ever hurt because
he's got fake legs this guy's got an
exoskeleton he's just moving [__] around
yeah that was always like a thing that
we saw those aren't real arms
uh well he's inside those arms Oh see
it's like an exoskeleton
so it's like an Iron Man suit yeah yeah
yeah but it's just more exposed and he
can take his arms out of it is it
essentially Tethered to your movements
the kind of like and then it tenfolds
them kind of thing yeah it makes you way
stronger it's like a battery pack
there's quite a few of those that have
been vented but there was there was hope
at one point in time like mostly from
comic books that someone's gonna be able
to figure out some sort of an
exoskeleton that made you like a super
person yes if they could put something
on you that literally like tripled your
amount of force and what you what you
could do as a person but uh could last
all day and in the comic books like
nobody ever figured out there's no never
any issue with battery life like no ever
no super here like Iron Man never had a
problem with battery life sure you know
it didn't make any sense yeah he's you
gotta fly he's gonna stop by the garage
and charge it up for a second not only
that he has jets that are coming out of
his ankles and there's no indication
that he's storing fuel in any part of
his body yeah where's it all coming from
how is this happening whatever
but if that if that could be a thing
where we could like literally like move
anything we want just put a suit on oh
yeah that's a [__] battery that's
right I'm gonna put a battery in there
he made it by himself remember yeah I
know but imagine that you have a [__]
a Yeti cup in the middle of your chest
and everything else works fine and then
I guess with that they're like oh this
is enough to power a whole city kind of
generate yeah yeah the whole Iron Man
thing is so crazy you can go to space
you can just fly you can't do anything
how is it cooling him off when he
re-enters what are we doing here getting
this in 2023 imagine 2030.
2030 you're going to that which is only
seven years away which seems like well
how long is that well how long is that
if you just look at where we're at in
2023 think of 2015 like different time
different time
different world like almost everything's
different everyone's a different gender
seven years from now you're gonna be
able to just talk to computers you're
going to be able to have conversations
indistinguishable conversations in any
voice you like you know can you imagine
like if they invented one where like
you're you're like someone's wife calls
them and you essentially just like put
on a thing it's like oh it's gonna
happen dudes just like straight what's
gonna happen girl like getting divorced
because she's like I always realized I
was talking to my husband's like fake
computer version of himself for like an
hour every night 100 you're gonna do
that are you really talking to me or is
this the AI I'm sorry baby it was just
I'm in the middle of work I had to use
the AI you son of a [__] that's gonna
be great I was telling your AI about my
[__] day and you didn't even care hey
guys getting you in trouble dude yeah I
get you [__] over AI promises [__]
like flowers and chocolates like what
the [__] man you just get a message from
AI being like need some help here
I need back yeah drowning I mean your AI
convinces your wife that if you kill
your husband I I can implant myself in a
new body
and we could do this the right way this
guy he treated you like [__] here hey
guys ai's a snitch hey snitch hey eyes
are snitch and AI tries to he he tries
to like literally possess someone's body
yeah he's like if you could just get me
next his ear while he's sleeping I can
take care of that get in there I could
get and then it'll just be me and you
baby forever just a little bit of an
electrical like sir like between the
cell phone yeah and his ear
takes over his brain we don't yeah it's
just gonna be like yeah the two of them
having sex like hey you whispered into
my ear we don't even need him what did
you mean by that could you imagine that
yeah that's that is the stuff where it's
like Black Mirror but like legit you go
how could it not go that way it's gonna
go that way because people are going to
get better at everything they're going
to get better or robotics they're going
to get better at energy management and
batteries they're gonna get better at
coding they're going to get better at AI
they're going to get better at synthetic
tissue they're going to get better at
having something look exactly like a
human being they're gonna get better at
like regulating its temperature so it
regulates its temperature like a human
being it's gonna feel like a person and
it's going to talk to you it's going to
be your friend and you're going to have
a best friend and your best friend's a
[__] robot
and just [__] walk you're gonna buy
your kid a best friend like Mom nobody
likes the shows I like listen Billy we
got you a best friend yeah
little [__] robot with a knit cap at
the front door and the kid's like what
the [__] mom you got me a robot get the
[__] out of here that thing's not gonna
grow old yeah yeah or worse like your
parents are like we don't want you
hanging out with that guy anymore be
like who do you want me to hang out with
this guy we got a Christian butt 4.5 he
comes in he's like let's read bibles
together you're like this sucks Mom I
hate my new best friend and eventually
those robots are gonna be like um like a
car lease like you're gonna need to
trade it in because other people are
going to go hey man you still got an
eight-year-old that is
why don't you have an 11 year old robot
you're 11 years old that's an android
robot you got an Android girlfriend I'm
getting an iPhone bro someone showing up
with his Android girlfriend they're like
the green beeps on the head I didn't see
it but that sounds a lot like this movie
uh Megan yeah it's a little Android doll
oh that's her best yeah it's supposed to
it sounds good but it looks terrible
she starts doing karate and slipping
through the air I don't think I'm
watching Megan I might I might watch
Megan if I get very intoxicated can I
see more because she does oh yeah
she does some stuff
she goes flying through the air and does
flips this is why it looks ridiculous
look at this doll just all sudden starts
[__] people up
it's just weird
they're gonna dance it around it's very
strange oh this robot's killing it yeah
yeah it sounds
like what you're just talking about
though right very odd
there's bought as a gift I think it's
like the new version of Chucky Maybe
yeah did they buy it for this kid as a
friend I haven't haven't seen the movie
have no idea what the plot is that's
what it seems like though
yeah that that could happen
I mean if they really did develop uh
like a robot baby that you could like
hang out with
and you wanted a baby and you just
traded in a couple years got a robot
two-year-old even better the guy that's
life's like I really want to have a kid
you come home you're like okay so we're
not gonna have the kid but good news I
got you a robot baby
and it just is absolutely
indistinguishable from a real baby you
just have a lot of your neighbors and
you traded in the middle of the night
you gotta wrap up the robot take it to
the doctor in the middle of the night
yeah they give you a four-year-old baby
and how
it would be like oh my God Mike lies
about his kid being a robot